madame sophie rofritsch pour le groupe
l'est républicain ma question s'adresse
à madame la ministre de l'éducation
nationale de l'enseignement supérieur et
de la recherche
madame la ministre après la réforme des
rythmes scolaires dans l'élémentaire
imposé sans aucune concertation acteurs
de la communauté éducative aux parents
et aux communes réforme dont soit dit en
passant vous refusez malgré les demandes
réitérées de notre groupe et de votre
propre majorité de nous communiquer
l'évaluation vous avez imposé malgré
l'opposition des syndicats enseignants
une réforme du collège dont l'unique
ambition est de niveler par le bas les
connaissances acquises par les
collégiens suppression des classes
bilangues suppression de l'apprentissage
du latin et du grec tant d'autres
attaques qui ne font sens que si on les
examine à la lumière d'un dogmatisme
inégalée par vos deux prédécesseurs
et pourtant dieu sait que la compétition
était rude voici maintenant que pour
parachever la déstabilisation complète
du collège vous cherchez en faire le
lieu où grâce à des formules qu'on peut
sans caricaturer qualifié de loufoques
puisqu'elles font par exemple
elle se fonde par exemple sur le schéma
des lignes du métro parisien
vous prévoyez toujours sans concertation
la refonte de la carte scolaire
de grâce laissez les collèges leurs
élèves leurs enseignants revenir à leur
mission initiale c'est-à-dire stabiliser
les conditions fondamentales développer
un socle culturel commun sur lequel le
lycée l'université pourront s'appuyer
ensuite vouloir faire porter au collège
le règlement de problèmes sociaux dont
aucune politique coercitive n'a pu venir
à bout comme celui de la mixité sociale
est vouée à l'échec
laissée aux établissements la liberté
construit une offre attractive laisser
leur un espace de liberté pour inventer
ce qui séduira les parents de tous
horizons
en somme arrêtez de les contraindre en
un mot madame la ministre
pourquoi ne choisissez vous pas
simplement de faire confiance à la
communauté éducative
merci madame ruth frith la parole à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
parlementaires
laissez moi parce que nous venons
d'apprendre la nouvelle
rendre hommage au chancelier helmut
schmidt qui vient de décéder
nous savons quelle a été sa place à la
tête de ce pays ami
l'allemagne et combien il a contribué
aux liens entre la france et l'allemagne
et il éclairait toujours par son verbe
et sa personnalité
la réflexion précisément sur le rôle et
la place de l'allemagne en europe et sa
relation privilégiée avec la france
madame
madame la députée la ministre de
l'éducation nationale est avec le
président l'a public dans une rencontre
avec les recteurs mais je réponds bien
volontiers à cette question parce que
elle est au coeur je crois du projet
pour le pays qui est le nôtre est plus
que jamais nous devons nous pourrions
nous retrouver au moins sur ce sujet là
mais je ne doute pas que c'est votre cas
nous retrouver sur la mobilisation de
l'école pour les valeurs de la
république et notamment dans la lutte
contre les inégalités à l'école des
réformes ont été engagées cette année
avec le renforcement de l'école
prioritaire les moyens supplémentaires
que nous donnons à l'école et puis bien
sûr la réforme des collèges et je suis
convaincu que cette réforme des collèges
celle qui est engagée et qui
s'appliquera à l'année prochaine qui va
de pair en plus avec une mobilisation
importante pour la place du numérique à
l'école est une réforme indispensable
nécessaire qui vise à donner plus de
moyens à l'école et plus de chance aux
élèves et face aux inégalités qui n'ont
cessé de se reproduire
depuis des années à l'école l'illégalité
en fonction du lieu de naissance d
origine sociale des quartiers où on
habite
il faut prendre à bras le corps cette
question là qui est celle de la mixité
sociale est le choix qui a été fait par
la ministre précisément concernant la
lutte contre cette création sociale ou
spatial c'est de partir de
l'expérimentation du terrain à travers
un certain nombre de départements 17 en
lien avec les établissements bien sûr
mais en lien aussi avec les conseils
départementaux et en partant de cette
expérience du terrain des échecs qui ont
été ceux de la majorité précédente qui a
voulu mettre en cause la carte scolaire
ce qui n'a absolument rien régler des
problèmes de montée des inégalités
à partir de cette expérimentation nous
tirerons les conclusions nécessaires
pour améliorer cette situation qui
devrait très honnêtement nous rassembler
parce que pour tous ceux qui ont des
enfants ou les enfants collège pour tous
ceux qui sont élus sur le terrain ils
savent bien combien aujourd'hui nous
faisons face à des situations
d'évitement à des collèges qui sont en
très grande difficulté alors plutôt que
d'être dedans
les affirmations catégoriques d'être
uniquement dans l'opposition pour être
le plaisir dans l'opposition si nous
pourrions nous retrouver sur cette belle
idée qui est celle de l'école
républicaine
et croyez moi nous sommes engagés parce
que s'il ya quelque chose qui peut
peut-être nous différencier et c'est une
bonne chose dans le débat public qui est
une certaine conception de l'égalité et
sans doute nous la partageons pas merci
monsieur le premier ministre la parole à
madame c